欢迎各位桌里今天这期摆车全说我是三刀。
今天这期节目咱们来聊一聊最近特别特别火的张雪机车创始人张雪的故事。
前两天大家应该刷手机的时候被一张照片给硬控住了，
是不是你不管喜欢不喜欢摩托车，
那张照片你肯定是有各种PS的版本在摩托车的塞道上面，
前面有一辆车跑得无影无踪，
然后后面第二名，第三名，第四名，第五名，
就几辆车子跟在那个地方，
中间控出了一大片灰色的绿青路面，
那我相信你懂赛车也好，不懂赛车也好，
你看到这张图片是什么感觉，
要么这个照片里面的第一名或者说是第一位车手被人套了一圈了，
就即将要被后面的车套了一圈了，
要么就是前面这个人是第一名，
后面那几个人跟他有很大的一个距离就完全追不上，
那实际上他就是第一名嘛对吧，
他领先了后面的几位车手将近4秒的时间，
在摩托车里面你想想看4秒是什么概念，
大家的时速基本上都是跑到200多公里每小时，
那么4秒，
但严格意义上讲是3.685秒，
那就是摇摇领先了嘛，
那么这个事情就发生在前几天，
在葡萄牙，
那葡萄牙这一场比赛赢了之后，
大家就知道了在中国有一个摩托车的品牌，
叫做张雪机车，
那么其实我在路上也不能说是经常，
因为大家我经常去看到有人骑摩托车，
我会去瞄一眼，
虽然我自己没有买摩托车，
我虽然有摩托车的驾照，
但大家都知道，
因为我三代单传家里祖训是不让去买摩托车的，
但是我想了想我觉得真的，
我得好好地去跟我们家的这个亲人要好好聊一下，
我妈妈肯定不管我嘛，
我爸也不再试了，
那我就剩个我老婆看能不能沟通一下，
不行我还是买一辆啊买一辆，
那天我发微博我也在讲，
我说如果安全一点，
我看我能不能去买一个踏板，
但是张雪摩托到目前为止没有踏板，
有说是27年，
也有说是28年他可能会去造踏板车，
好这是题外话我们还是说到张雪啊，
那么张雪机车相当于是一战成名，
现在全网都在聊，
为什么呢，
因为国人都喜欢看这个中国人打败洋人啊，
就感觉特别的爽啊，
不管是看这个运动比赛也好啊，
其实摩托车也是也算是运动比赛嘛对吧，
就觉得说，
往日都是欧美对吧，
欧美这个日，
加上日本啊这些摩托车的品牌就统治这个市场，
统治这个比赛，
但是现在来了一个中国人，
而且我觉得今年你还发现啊，
今年这个不管是汽车赛事还是摩托赛事，
好像中国的这个身影就特别的频繁，
因为我前面刚聊过F1，
今年上海的F1也是扮得非常的火，
可以说是历年来最初圈的一年，
那我也分析过前几年，
为什么F1赛事还算是比较火，
你比方说疫情中间停灯那么多年，
突然在上海的这一次的F1的赛事，
很多的全球的粉丝都过来看，
那么再后来就是这个周冠语对吧，
大家都是为了看它，
但是经典就明显是背后有一股官方的力量再去推，
但是张雪计车我可以明确的讲，
或者大家应该一看就明白，
这里面是不会有官方的身影的，
因为张雪接受采访的时候讲的全都是大实话，
非常的直白，记者问他说你为什么选择重庆啊，
他也说因为重庆这个摩托车整个的供应链非常的完整，
就是世界上任何一款摩托车你放到重庆来都能造得出来，
然后他又紧跟着问说重庆给没给你相关的政策啊，
补助啊之类的，
然后他就问记者说你是需要我说假话还是说真话呢，
说场面话还是说真话，
记者说你要不说真话吧，
一分钱没给，
然后记者说那你还是说场面话吧，
然后这个在网上都能看得到，
我估计到了后面可能是把前半段给删了，
只留后面的场面话，
因为现在自从他火了以后，
据说是重庆这边给他披了两百亩的地，
然后又给他引入了很多的资金，
我看到一篇报道，
报道的标题也是让我鸡皮疙瘩掉一地，
叫做什么用资本的耐心助力降人的初心，
我说这个真的中国文字伯大精神啊，
这个词写的非常的好啊，
那么至于张雪机社将来真的能不能成为一个全球知名品牌，
能成为一个你别说是百年车企吧，
你哪怕将来能跟本田啊，
喀巴萨奇啊，
去跟亚马哈去搬满手腕，
其实我觉得还早呢，
但是对于资本来讲，
这是个好的机会，
所以浙江那边那个是叫浙创投吧，
就浙江创业投资，
一下子就给了几千万嘛，
然后后面很多一些投资人也是想跟进嘛，
这个是题外话就不讲了，
反正就是一窩疯的资本就涌入，
对吧,
你甚至于有没有可能他将来在，
就像华为这种对吧，
就带一点，
我懂得都懂啊，
对不对，
你不买你就不，
对吧,
这个都不说，
大家都知道什么意思，
所以我觉得这事情到后面有可能会，
有可能会被这个，
怎么讲的媒体给吵到最后就有点变质了，
而我是觉得张雪，
他当时记者这个采访的时候他也说了嘛，
他说其实我不想接受采访，
他说你看你们所有的记者能进来采访我，
那都是找了关系的，
是不是，
就讲都是大实话，
那我觉得，
我是希望虽然我不认识这个人，
我是希望这个张雪这个哥们，
虽然他比我小三岁啊，
他八七年出生了，
他能够一直保持初心，
他能够一直是，
就是真真真正的去打造，
一款,
能跟国外的这些摩托车搬手万的，
我不管是，
赛道机器也好，
还是民用的这种小踏板，
少走二十年的弯路，
我为什么喜欢踏板，
就是因为我想少走二十年的弯路，
你不管造哪一个系列的设型，
如果真的能把品质造好，
如果你真的能把这个性能造上去，
我觉得是ok的，
因为你看，
张雪他还有个习惯是什么，
就是他每一个月，
还是每一周啊，
他是要去做一次直播，
是直接跟用户去联系，
你在网上能收到很多关于他跟用户直播的那个片段，
也很有意思，
有的人跟他投诉嘛，
说你的车子我，
吸火吸了好几次，
然后找你们的社会后，
然后说是给我处理没处理，
有的人说我上次联系你，
你说帮我去处理，
结果我到门店门店，
又拖了我一个月，
然后你就听到他那个直播间里面那个视频，
他是二创的嘛，
就一直你逼逼，
你你我逼逼逼逼，
一直在逼，
为什么一直逼逼逼逼逼逼啊，
因为他一直在说脏话嘛，
他直接骂他的那些，
骂他的那些高管，
所以他是一个，
很牛掰的创始人，
但他不一定是一个很牛掰的管理者，
但是呢，
因为这个公司现在目前没做大，
所以以他这种英雄式的人物，
我觉得带领这个团队是没有问题的，
这也是我曾经在聊，
七车之家的时候，
我也讲过这句话，
我说理想是七车之家的创始人，
但是理，
但是七车之家这个公司，
的创始人应该算是情致，
为什么这么讲呢，
就是理想他确确实实是发起七车之家，
这个公司的这个或者说七车之家这个名字，
都是由他去去创造出来的，
但是七车之家之所以能上市，
能做那么大，
能成为资本上运作，
最后卖给平安，
然后再一步一步就套现什么的，
我觉得这背后最根本的，
是因为他引入了这种国际性的人才，
而绝对不是理想把他带到这么高的一个高度，
理想是符合，
就是他符合做内容，
做产品，
但是情致是符合做公司，
去聊资本，
所以一个大的公司想要做的，
就是走出中国走上全球，
一定是要有这种配合的，
因为你的能力相对是有限的，
你不去找那种就是玩资本的，
华尔街的那些创投的，
或者是你像做这种搞上市IPO的这种，
你不可能做那么大的，
管理的形式也不一样，
我曾经在节目里面聊过嘛，
理想就是我们打个比方，
理想在他们如果是进行五星级酒店，
理想如果在前台看到有一本杂志没有归位，
那他肯定直接就直接找，
看到哪个人就骂哪个人嘛，
看到哪个大堂经理指着鼻子就一顿骂，
但你要知道你是五星级酒店的董事长，
一个大堂经理跟你中间差多少个级别，
但是情质有可能是看到这个杂志在桌上没放回去，
拍张照片回到办公室，
然后他会找他就是直接汇报的下属，
然后把这个总经理拉到办公室来说一下，
说这个事情虽然不大，
但是我已经不是第一次看到了，
就说明在员工培训流程的执行方面，
是有问题的，
所以你看你能不能给我一个计划，
比方说全员或者是大堂的这些相关的工作人员，
做一个重新的培训，
输导让大家去更加的规范化，
所以说情质的做法跟理想做法肯定是不一样的，
那么放到张雪这个人身上来讲的话，
他目前公司小，
他这种就是属于草莽的气质，
就是野路子或者不是讲野路子吧，
就是这种粗放的管理形式，
没什么问题，
但是你往大了看，
你特别是你像重新现在给他两百亩地，
又是几个亿的资金往里砸，
这公司迅速的膨胀，
他能不能厚度住，
所以这个时候我觉得就需要有非常牛白的管理人才来付出他了，
好我们聊张雪这个人还是要先从这个比赛开始聊，
很多人可能跟我一样，
就是平时也不太关注摩托车比赛，
这个咱们有一说一，
你不懂就是不懂，
你明明不是个摩托车迷，
你不要因为张雪现在火了，
然后感觉自己好像就对摩托车有多么的热爱一样的，
就喜欢就是喜欢，
你不喜欢就是不喜欢，
对于很多人来讲摩托车，
最多也就是个交通工具，
对吧,
现在有些人是把它当成是一个休闲娱乐的小玩具，
周末的时候开出去，
我应该叫奇术去了，
奇术去放空放空自己，
对吧,
那么我确实也平时不怎么关注这个摩托车比赛，
那么最多也就是跟大家一样，
听说过这个摩托机屁，
那么前段时间我不是去马来西亚过年的时候玩了一下吗，
对吧,
那个落地的机场旁边，
雪帮国际赛道，
那这就是摩托机屁，
马来西亚大奖赛，
还有就是官方测试经常用的赛道之一，
那么张雪这次参加的这个比赛呢，
它不是摩托机屁，
它是WSBK这个体系里面的叫World SSP，
它跟摩托机屁最大的区别在于，
就是摩托机屁相当于是摩托车圈的FE，
就是它这里面的车子都是纯赛车，
它不是说我们在马路上能买到的，
FE赛车你也不可能买得到，
当然你也不一定买得起，
买得起你不一定修得起，
修得起你不一定养得起，
那么这里面很多的技术和成本，
普通消费者肯定是接触不到的，
而这个WSBK呢，
它这个比赛核心是量产车为基础，
也就是说参赛的车辆你得要先上市，
你去销售能量产，
能通过赛事认证的车型，
然后在规则允许的范围之内做有限的改装，
就是为了平衡嘛，
平衡大家的这个，
就是怎么讲的，不管是马力也好，
还是平衡这个每台车的基本的这样的一个参数，
那么同时呢，
赛事还会有一套性能平衡机制，
就是尽量别让某一个这个一家独大的人，
就是大到大家都没办法去玩，
对吧，你比赛比的就是，
大家比较均衡去竞技嘛，
那么说白了，
摩托机屁呢，
那比的就是，
你要如果有赛道的黑科技，
那你可以去狠狠的干对手，
对吧,
谁家的黑科技更狠，
谁家的极限更高，
但是呢，
这个WSBK啊，
它比的就是谁家的量产车的底子更好，
底子更硬，
那么在同样的规则之下，
大家把发动机底盘，
调校做的更加的明白，
所以大家可以理解为，
就是摩托车圈的这个WSBK，
就更接近汽车圈的防车赛，
对吧，防车赛，
你比如说量产的高尔夫GTI，
量产的咱们国产像领克零三这种车，
那底子到底好不好，
你经过这个规则范围内的改装，
拿到赛道上面去比一圈，
那么立马就看得出来了，
所以呢，
张雪的这一次夺冠，
应该讲韩定量是特别高的，
那不仅你是圈内的人，
对这个是非常认可，
我一看了很多的文章，
真的是非常的认可，
看一看，
现在网上就铺天盖地各种视频，
采访,
还有一些图文，
你就应该知道，
就是咱们国内现在造摩托车，
其实底子并不差，
但是我观察下来，
现在这个摩托车的大环境，
就有点像当年中国的汽车市场，
就是你要如果买一个国产车，
那你除非就是没有钱嘛，
对吧,
你没有钱，
你去买那些长的也是比较山寨的，
那技术也不是特别先进的，
只能说是能开，
只能说是空间搞的大大的，
然后所谓的配置给你搞的高高的，
那至于说开个几年坏不坏，
零部件的这个耐用程度怎么样，
底盘是不是稀碎，
那你要如果不关心这些，
你只是图便宜，
你可以买，
我在网上看到大家的，
对于国产摩托车的这种评论，
整体来讲就是这样，
说白了就是这个买不起合资的，
买不起本田的，
买不起亚马哈的，
那你只能是推而求其次，
你去买国产，
那是不是国产摩托车真的这么拉跨，
大家如果有买过的，
你可以在评论区里面一起交流交流，
因为毕竟我不是摩托车车主，
我也没有实际去买过，
我不好去忘家评论，
我只能说，
第一个从我身边的人，
你比方说我们公司就有两台，
有两个是平时骑摩托车的，
然后另外就是我通过网上，
我看到很多的评论，
基本就这样的一个评价，
所以这个圈子到底怎样，
咱也不得而知，
那么我在网上也查了一下，
有一篇报道挺有意思的，
讲的是这个越南市场，
就是曾经在2000年代初期，
越南市场中国的摩托车，
能占到整个市场的80%到90%，
非常夸张哦，
但是到了2026年，
整个越南的摩托车市场，
中国的摩托车现在还占多少，
你知道吗，
还占1%中国，
但其实严格意义上来讲，
如果把中国台湾也算进来的话，
但大概在5%到6%，
因为台湾的摩托车，
在这个越南市场上，
还能占到3%到5%，
但是咱们这里的只占1%，
所以中国台湾那边叫三阳，
三阳摩托车，
应该说在台湾运营的还是比较成功的，
基本上是市场的前5名，
国内的这些品牌就，
相对来讲就是只是拼价格，
然后因为拼价格，
所以就大家恶性竞争嘛，
然后质量又不行，
售后又不行，
所以市场份额从当年80%-90%，
一路跌到现在只剩1%左右，
然后日本这些品牌在当地，
本田是最为市场占有力最高的嘛，
能占到80%左右，
然后亚马哈紧随其后，
所以我当时看到这个数据，
我觉得也挺心酸的，
但是整个的海外摩托车市场的一个缩影，
因为我只看到了越南市场的一个数据报道，
好，那我们还是回到比赛上来讲，
那么刚刚前面说了，
就是这个赛事WSBK相当于是量产车作为底子，
然后适当的在规则范围内去改装，
但是它这个组别是SSP，
我当时看了一个采访，
就是问张雪说这个比赛你能不能跟我介绍一下，
她说这个比赛你可以理解为，
就有点像你比如说打篮球，
它会有这种高中联赛，
也会有大学联赛，
有CBA,
它这个相当于就是相当于是高中的比赛，
你在网上的话还有更高级别的，
她说这个是中量组，
那么她将来也会去挑战更高级别的赛事，
所以张雪其实我觉得这个人骨子里面，
就是以赛车为身，
或者说是以赛车作为他的这种信念，
他就是要去造这个车辆去打比赛，
去获得奖项，
从一开始大家在网上看到的户南卫视采访他，
那个视频在网上是不是很流传，
其实这个视频很早就有了，
我很早很早就看过这个视频，
但是我早年知道这个小伙子并不知道他叫张雪，
我也不知道张雪机车跟这个人有关系，
也不是因为这次比赛我才知道，
因为毕竟我是做汽车内容的，
有的时候刷着刷着，
我也能刷到张雪机车，
这个名字有点意思啊，
以人的名字来命名的，
你说春风摩托，
我也不知道哪个人叫春风，
对吧,
你说凯月，
哪个人叫凯月，
我也不知道，
但是这个人叫张雪，
那一定是这个人，
牌子叫张雪，
人的名字叫张雪，
然后后来我应该是我记不到哪一年了，
反正早几年我就知道张雪跟张雪摩托。
是当年湖南采访的那个小伙子，
是同一个人，
但是我当时仅仅就认为，
他可能就是一个类似于小公司，
相当于就是怎么讲的比较偏个性化的一个，
可能甚至于就像个改装场一样，
所以我对他真的一点都不了解，
我对他当时坐摩托车，
我的理解就是一个，
就像个疯子一样的造车狂人，
也许造了一个比较偏小众的车，
那么至于说是有资本在推动他，
还是说他一边挣一点小钱，
再投入进去小范围的众筹形式的，
去卖车造车，
我不是很了解，
但是我跟大家一样，
也是这一次一占成名之后，
我开始去大范围的，
花了大量的时间精力去搜索他的一些过往，
搜索他跟这个机车品牌的一些过往，
我才知道，
我还真的是非常厉害，
20多年一直坚持，
一直要去造这种打比赛的车，
包括这些车也能去量产，
也能去卖，
那么这辆车是什么车呢，
这台比赛的车是他们家的叫820RR的赛化版本，
那么参赛组别就SSP吗，中量组，
那么在这个组别里面，
或者说在这个赛事里面，
大家能看到的很多都是老面孔，
你比如说像杜卡迪，
像烘达本田，
还有大家比较熟悉的像亚马哈，
还有就是可能你不玩摩托车，
不太了解的就是卡瓦萨奇穿旗，
穿旗小忍者我也蛮喜欢的，
那你说这些品牌造摩托车，
那动辄都是十几年几十年了，
所以玩赛道，玩摩托车的这种比赛是人家看家本领，
而且你像杨马哈，
杨马哈之前在这个组别里面可以说是统治级的，
连续六年都是拿的年度冠军，
但是你要知道，
杨马哈的那辆R9，
它之前在国内落地要十几万，
那如果说你想买的话，
这个车子不是说十几万就能买得到，
你还要加价还要排队，
因为像这种进口车型确实都比较紧张，
有人是这么说的嘛，
当时我记得是说本田，
说本田还中国区的价格，
和中国区的价格是完全不一样的，
就是中国的本田是最贵嘛，
我也不知道是真是假，
如果是玩摩托车的，
对这方面价格比较了解的，
可以来说一说，
但是最近这两年好像摩托车价格降价还是挺厉害的，
之前我看还上了热搜了，
那么张雪的这家公司是2024年才成立的，
就是张雪机车，
所以非常年轻啊，
今年是2026年，
也就才两三年的时间，
那么他现在反手套出了一辆车，
就直接拿了一个这种世界级赛事的一个冠军啊，
当然了这个不是年度总冠军啊，
就是分战赛，
那么更让人想不到就是这台820RR，
它的售价多少钱，
这个很关键，
我在网上看到很多的人去PS那张图片，
就是跑在第一名的那辆，
只有四万多块钱，
然后后面不是十几万，
就是二十几万，
所以你要知道四万多块钱的，
一辆中国造的摩托车，
去挑战那些动辄都是十几万，
二十几万的，
甚至更贵的，
这些国际大牌，
那么你把人家还甩了一个将近四秒，
拿了一个冠军，
所以这个事情你不管从哪个角度看，
那绝对都是爽文，
大家都喜欢看短剧是吧，
喜欢看那种爽文的这个文章，
我觉得这真的真的就草根利息，
各种方面的因素全部剧造一点，
那么剧造这个点之后，
你说它不火，
那是没有天理的，
所以一定是巨大的流量，
但是因为我本身也是玩流量，
也是做自媒体，
我太清楚了，
就是这个流量突然涌入过来的时候，
其实往往这个地方就是是非之地，
就是是非之地，
如果说就是张雪这个人，
他真的想好好去做实业的话，
这个时候最好是淡化处理，
因为名气有了，
就是你当名气上升的时候，
这个时候你要低调，
就是你的皇冠越重，
其实你平时做的事情就越要低调，
你的名气越大，
你这个时候越需要去消失在人们的实业里面，
甚至于我说句不好听的，
也找一些专业人士去减一减这个热搜，
上热搜的量，
因为这两天我看这个热搜量实在是太大，
而且很多人都在蹭他的热点，
我是昨天还是今天看到那个，
陈光彪，
陈光彪这个这个彪哥真的是什么热点都蹭啊，
他说要把他的那个1000多万的老斯莱斯刚买的，
他还特别强调2026款新款1000多万老斯莱斯，
要送给张雪，
让他做接待，
说句实在话，
像这种事情我觉得没有必要，
而且我个人觉得第一个张雪不可能要他的这个老斯莱斯，
第二个，
你说你是选你有钱呢，
还是说你真的是无常是给他，
你要如果是无常，
你可以不用给张雪吗？
你可以去比方说跟他合作一个项目，
做他的投资人，
你这个钱你说你随便用，
我不用你还，
我只是为了支持你的这个摩托车的研发事业，
对吧,
标革有钱嘛，
也很感动嘛，
对吧,
就中国出了这么一个品牌，
你就直接给他钱不就行了嘛，
给他1000万，
所以网友下面评论特别搞笑，
说收啊，
为什么不收啊，
陈光彪就是读你不会收嘛，
你收完之后，
转手就把它给卖了，
卖完之后就拿这个钱成立一个研发基金，
就你不行那个研发组，
就用光彪的名字去命名嘛，
光彪研发组，
就网友蛮聪明的，
给钱不要嘛是不是，
但是不可能的，
送上门的这种白痴的东西，
它一定是比付费的更贵，
就像玩游戏一样的，
你反而那些让你充值的不会算太贵，
那些免费的反而更贵，
所以以前摩托世界，
你算了算你比账，
其实你要天天玩你包月，
其实比充电卡要划算，
是吧,
一收到摩托世界，
大家就开始新闻了是吧，
也没有老摩托啊，
嘿嘿嘿，
好，我们进去往下聊，
那么杨马哈的那辆R6，
在国内是卖了十几万，
那张雪的车只有四万多块钱，
而且是真正真正能买得到的，
我们车圈呢，
很多人也是玩摩托车的，
对吧,
其实这一波热点真的，
你让我挺怀念，
我们的那一个车圈的定流了，
真的,
如果它要是在的话，
那,
这一波绝对又是最适合它的，
这个,
每一天它都能发很多条，
因为它毕竟这方面是很专业的，
那么,
严创老师啊，
也是骑摩托车的，
也特别喜欢摩托车，
那么他也是定力量，
也是定力量这个，
同款的冠军车型，
那么因此呢，
在我们车圈里面，
其他玩摩托车的，
像之前我隔壁的这个波克张大胆，
我跟他一起这个做了一期节目，
他就聊到很多车圈的事，
那么这一次我也问他，
我说哎，张雪你熟不熟悉，
他跟我说了这么一件事，
他说他参加的，
摩托车的试驾会啊，
品牌发布啊，
绝大多数都是进口的，
这些品牌，进口的摩托，
那进口摩托车的这个圈子呢，
他跟国产的摩托车这个圈子，
我听他的意思啊，
感觉还不是一个圈，
就是他跟进口的这个圈子里面呢，
不管是试车的，
还是做自媒体内容的，
还是厂方的人都很熟悉，
但是跟，
就是做国产的摩托车这个圈子呢，
就不是很熟，
哎，这个有点意思啊，
这个我在想是不是，
这个我们早期的汽车媒体人，
也是这样子，
他们是不是也是跟大众风田啊，
奥地宝马啊都很熟，
但是那个时候可能跟，
吉利啊，
跟什么齐瑞啊，
跟比亚迪啊走的就不是很近，
那这种要讲的话，
就要讲到可能20年前了，
对吧,
就中国的国产车型还没崛起的时候，
那么当然了，
那个品牌更加的有技术含量，
那个品牌更受大众欢迎，
那媒体也愿意去报道这些品牌，
是不是，
它结束度更高嘛，
那么关于摩托车啊，
关于这个摩托车赛事啊，
我们就聊那么多，
接下来呢，
我们就讲一讲张学这个人，
他是怎么一步一步走到今天的，
那么很多人会觉得说，
但这肯定是个爽文，
其实我觉得啊，
这更像是一个立志文，
而不像是个爽文，
因为爽文说句实在话，
里面的很多情节还是比较夸大的，
但是这个哥们其实你仔细推测一下啊，
就是你往前看，
翻看他的每一步，
他其实并没有特别的夸大，
而是这个人，
就怎么讲呢，
很匠啊，
就认准了一件事情，
他有点像哪一个啊，
有点像那个胖东莱，
大家还记得吗，
胖东莱开超市的那个人，
他认准了这个事，
他就这么做，
别人怎么反对怎么样，
都无所谓，
他就是很纯粹，
就是我只认这个目标，
我的生活除了吃喝睡觉，
那么剩下来的事情，
一切都是铺在工作上面，
然后我之前还看了一个，
就是我很好奇，
就是张学的老婆，
到底是什么样的一个女性啊，
我还去查了一下，
结果好小不小，
查了两段视频，
第一段视频呢，
是有一个女记者去采访她老婆，
就像小闺蜜一样，
两个人聊天，
我觉得聊得很好，
感觉就是那种，
也不能叫淡薄名利吧，
就是她是，
你只要给她一口饭吃，
她就能给你把家里一起打你的好好的，
然后呢，
她也特别的去体贴张学，
她讲过一句话，
叫什么，
说爱她就成就她，
是怎么说来着，
就是不是让她成为你想要的那个人，
而是你成就，
怎么讲来着，
就是反正意思就是，
你要让她成为她想要的人，
而不是把她成为你想要的那个样子，
就有一句很经典的话，
我也是说不上来啊，
因为这个地方是脱稿随便聊的，
说句实在话，
我觉得啊，
听下来她整个采访，
采访我觉得真的，
就是老婆要是如果闲会的话，
这老公真的是可以放手去干，
就是往往她能一往无前的去冲，
而且我看到她，
就她老婆她有个习惯，
就是她是喜欢写日记，
当然人家日记也是不会公开的了，
她也讲到了当年就是张学，
去看修理场的时候，
张学应该是很早就结婚了，
也有看她，
我推测了一下她年龄二十小几，
应该她就结婚了，
那么她日记里面就写到，
说跟她的这个伯伯叔叔啊，
亲戚朋友啊，
就借钱，
这家借三万，
这家借五万，
她妈是借的最多的，
我看她那个里面写到，
她妈是借了六万，
八万,
五万,
六万,
那七七八八算在一起，
她妈应该借给她，
估计有十几二十几万了，
所以怎么讲呢，
我觉得张学，
虽然说她是一个礼仪家庭，
但是呢，
她周围的亲人对她还是非常好的，
所以她的内心充满着阳光，
我觉得更多的，
并不是说她在那个环境下，
她没有了父爱，
不叫没有父爱不爱吧，
就是她可能就是一个礼仪家庭，
奶奶带大，
但是她周围的亲戚对她非常好，
朋友对她非常好，
那么当然了，
她本身自己的性格也是那种，
就是这个人，
你跟她相处，
你肯定是不会吃亏的，
虽然说她脾气很差，
她很暴躁，
可能说阿哥外面都很直，
直来直往，
但她是一个很有意思的人，
我身边也有这样的人，
就是很纯粹，
很非常的纯粹，
她对于金钱这一块，
她不傻，
她其实心里面都很清楚，
你在占她的便宜，
她也很清楚，
她身上可能都里面只有三百块钱，
但是请你吃饭可能要花这个两百八十块钱，
或者甚至就三百块钱全部花掉，
无所谓，
她下一顿可能就不知道去哪吃了，
但是只要兄弟们开心，
她是愿意把这个钱撒出去的，
这种人是绝对适合创业型的人才，
打江山，
一帮兄弟，
对吧,
千金散去，
兄弟就聚集在一起了，
但是你让她守江山，
会比较难，
因为她这种好爽的性格，
往往到了江山已经打下来了，
你需要去稳固的时候，
再有这种好爽的性格就很难去稳固，
所以我们就讲一些这种题外话了，
我们继续往下聊，
大家感兴趣，
我刚刚讲的在网上你都能收到，
她老婆的采访，
包括她的采访，
她老婆的第二个视频，
她老婆有出镜，
但是她老婆没说话，
是什么呢？
是当年张雪在凯月车队的时候，
好像发生了一件什么事，
说找了一个车队，
然后给100万让他们跑四场，
后来其中有个工作人员，
在群里面反正也不知道怎么沟通的，
让他们加跑一场，
那么车队的意思就是加跑一场，
那你肯定要再多给我25万嘛，
那大概是这么个意思啊，
那么结果呢就跑了，
跑完之后呢，
这个群里面那个人也离职了，
但是后来再去找凯月，
那那个25万好像就没结，
还是这么回事，
那网上有人是这么讲，
我也不知道，
就看到那个哥们一直在直播间里面，
就不停的跟现场的工作人员吵架，
在那个张雪机车的展台上面，
好几年前的事情了吧，
然后后来张雪就来了，
张雪来了其实也，
态度非常好，
意思就是，
你有事就说事对吧，
你需要我们解决什么，
然后我现在也不在凯月了，
但是凯月的负责人我也喊过来了，
对吧,
你们可以坐在一起，
那当年这个事情我确确实实有参与，
据说是他撮合的凯月车队跟，
凯月跟那个车队一起来合作，
他说那我们就坐下一起聊，
那那个哥们很转，
那个哥们的意思就是说，
你不是很懂车吗，
但是我就想知道你懂什么车啊，
你根本就不懂摩托车啊，
你懂什么呀，
你根本就不懂，
你不专业，
你是不是不专业，
那哥们就非常的甚视灵人，
所以我在想，
这摩托车毕竟是个小圈子，
如果在汽车圈，
如果在汽车圈有一个人站出来，
哪怕你就是车队的人，
你胆敢是站在，
你本管是雷军你就别想了，
你站在雷军面前，
你这个人就不要在互联场，
往上混了，
余生冬你也不用想了，
你想你敢跟余生冬这么对话，
那你直接消失在互联网，
那我觉得就是你，
卫健军对吧，
你比方说你站在卫健军的面前，
你说卫健军老卫，
你根本就不懂摩托车，
你专业吗，
你不专业，
你开个直播，
你试试看，
我觉得就光是，
卫健军他玩摩托车自立，
应该能把那个人怼，
怼了,
就话都说不出来吧，
哈哈哈，
你根本就说其他的了，
要领个老王，
你去怼他，
你怼老王，
你说你不会造车，
哎呀,
我当然看那个视频，
那为什么那个视频里面有张雪老婆呢，
当时张雪讲了这么一句话，
张雪说，
哪个世界级的摩托车品牌，
试车不死人啊，
然后他老婆赶紧上去，
把他嘴给捂住了，
就意思，
你不要讲话，
但是张雪就说把他给挥开，
他还要讲，
就他这种性格，
我讲这个细节是什么意思呢，
就这个人脑子里面想什么，
他有的时候他，
不,
应该这么讲，
心里面想什么，
他有的时候不会太过老子，
直接就是直，
我们南京话讲就直场子，
直接就说出来了，
我就是这么想的，
对吧,
这就是个真理，
这件事情就是这么样子的，
但你要知道在互联网上有些话，
他即使是对的，
但是在这种场合下你去说出来，
就很容易产生在互联网上的这种曲解，
现在目前我看到一种状态是什么呢，
就是张雪风神，
就是大家喜欢造神，
他把张雪造成了一个，
中国摩托车圈子里面的神一样的人物，
那么就导致，
你看今天网上又有个热搜，
我在录节目的时候，
因为我中间节目稍微断了一下，
我跟孩子，
还有我老婆出去吃了个饭，
我当时吃饭的时候去刷，
我就看到了，
说凯乐机车道歉，
为什么道歉啊，
说凯乐机车在直播间里面，
意思就是凯乐也拿过冠军，
不是只有这个张雪机车拿过冠军，
我们拿的冠军比他还要早，
那么这也是事实，
这也是事实，
只不过直播间那个人讲话的时候也有点转，
就是你要知道摩托车这个圈子，
这个世界相当于是个出圈的世界，
那么在这个世界之前，
其实除了摩托车的粉丝，
关注摩托车的人，
没有人去关注，
你别说什么摩托车赛事了，
你甚至就是摩托车那些新品发布，
也不会有人去关注的，
但是现在顺着这个出圈呢，
大家都想抓这个流量，
那么凯乐的直播间讲出这样的话，
我觉得，
其实从内心角度来讲，
我也能理解，
大家虽然看上那个直播的那个回放，
我觉得也不太妥，
但是凯乐的人就站出来道歉了，
为什么，
因为被网友骂上热搜了，
那么这里面就讲到了一个什么点呢，
代表中国的摩托车产业，
他是不是为中国摩托车的这个产业，
做出最大的贡献，
是不是就他最懂车，
就慢慢慢慢这个话题就被带跑偏了，
因为张学本人也没说过他最懂车呀，
张学讲过这么一句话说，
这个叫什么，
造摩托车我不一定是国内最好的，
但是,
我至少改变了摩托车的售后生态，
他为什么讲这句话呢，
因为,
就是他不是有那个，
就是张学直接面对用户嘛，
对吧,
甚至他有一个直播片段是这样的，
一个用户说，
我是新手，
我也不怪你的车，
他说我是没把位好，
没把我好在路上开，
然后中间有一个好像是散落的石头，
还是什么的，
然后他压上去之后，
他说差一点，
连命都没有了，
那么张学当时的意思就是说，
哎,
你不用着急，
我们出钱，
我们找法务，
我们陪你去打这个官司，
去找这个什么陆正啊之类的，
让他们去索赔，
他说,
因为我们之前遇到过一个案例，
就是当时索赔是成功了，
只不过是因为诉讼打官司之后才成功的，
他说你不用烦，
你这些事情都不用管，
我来给你找法务，
一个用户自己开摩托车，
在路上压倒一个砖头，
然后摔翻了，
车子包废啊之类的，
他帮用户去打这个官司，
其实这个事情跟他有关系吗，
没有关系，
但是缺令的人可能会觉得说，
你是在作秀，
但是对于他来讲，
他可能就是我首先，
你别管我作秀不作秀，
这是我的风格，
而且这件事情，
我是不是时时在在去做了，
这是我的态度，
对吧,
那么中国的摩托车，
他就是，
我就用这样的一种社会服务模式，
是我张雪计车玩出来的，
那我反过来讲，
这件事情的本质是什么，
是他的操作行为，
其实是跟像我们汽车圈的这些公关行为，
是完全相反的，
汽车圈的公关行为是，
谁提出问题，
解决这个提问题的人，
但是这个张雪计车，
或者这个摩托车子里面的，
至少这个品牌在我看来，
是谁提出问题，
他也是解决提问题的人，
但是解决的方式不同，
他是真正解决提问题的人提出的问题，
国内的汽车圈是解决提问题的人，
没有问题，
就解决他就解决的问题，
解决这个人就解决问题，
说到这个话，
我作为汽车圈媒体，
我也只能说到这了，
有些事情一句两句也说不清，
因为这里面确实有的也是黑盒操作的，
黑香黑盒操作，
那么我们还是回到张雪这个故事上来，
有中间随便聊聊嘛，
有的时候一聊一聊跑题，
从张雪老婆到张雪吵架，
那么最近大家都开始翻看他之前的一段采访了，
我节目开头我也讲，
这个采访其实很多年前我也看过，
但是我没想到是后来的，
也没想到是这一次一战成名的张雪机车，
这个小伙子，
20年前的视频，
当时湖南卫视有个晚间新闻，
那个节目很有流量，
那个时候不叫流量了，
就是很有收视率，
然后当时张雪应该是在淮化，
他本身出身是在湖南省淮化市，
麻洋苗族自治县，江口虚镇，田家湾村，
他是在这个地方出身的，
当时他19岁，
19岁的时候他应该是从这个叫做麻洋县，
然后去到了淮化市，
湖南的朋友你可以说一说这个地方到底怎样，
因为我当时查了一下他们这个县这个城市，
人口不是特别的多，
我当时是这么问的，
我说湖南省的淮化市，
大概相当于江苏省的哪个市，
就从它的经济人口各方面，
结果AI给我的答案是没有一个城市像，
它是最多能够跟它差不多的，
就是联云港什么灌云啊，
联云港的灌云跟它稍微像一点，
但是灌云我看了一下人口数量70多万，
包括它的整个的GDP，
联云港应该算我们江苏省最低的了，
说是它的两倍以上，
然后说但是这个地方很有意思，
有很多好吃的，
这个是个什么叫什么秘局啊，
然后说这里还有有山有水，
它是个农业比较好的一个地方，
然后可能也是个小的旅游景点，
我当时看了一下，
挺有意思的，
它是出现在这个地方，
那么后来从县里面等于是到了市里面，
那么当时它知道了，
湖南卫视有这么一个晚间新闻很有流量，
然后要到淮化市这边来去进行一个采访，
那么当时19岁的张雪呢，
就拼命的给这个电视台打电话，
打电话什么意思呢，
就是忽悠它，
就是说我有这个摩托车的特技，
然后我今天19岁，
我开了一个修理厂，
修理摩托车的，
我想表演给你看，
这是个好的题材，
那么人家肯定是要问啊，
对吧，你毛随自建，推荐选题，
你到底目的是什么呢，
它其实说的也很直白，
就是它想通过这个电视台，
能不能让车队给看到，
它想进车队，
想当塞车手，
一个19岁的村子里的农村的一个修理厂的一个修理工，
然后想要当职业的摩托车的塞车手，
这个故事呢，
他们就觉得有那么一点话题性，
然后这个电视台的人，
就记者跟司机两个就过来准备去拍他了，
那么张雪呢，
我前面也说了，
因为父母离异跟奶奶长大，
然后呢，
也是借钱去拍修理厂，
从小就特别喜欢摩托车，
对吧,
那个视频特别搞笑，
大家一定要找到语言视频去看一看，
不管是这个话外音的配音也好，
然后整个的那个，
主持人跟他的对话也好，
然后当然最有看点的，
就是张雪面对镜头时候，
他的表情跟说的每一句话就特别有意思，
我觉得不仅仅是励志，
然后也是带一点点这种悲情的喜剧啊，
黑色幽默在里面啊，
那么这段采访视频啊，
20年前采访视频啊，
大家什么地方都不用去搜了，
你直接去Bilibili，
上湖南卫视的主账号，
他们主账号竟然把这个视频的高清版本直接给发出来的，
完整版一秒不差的，
特别有意思，
那个弹幕都爆炸了我跟你说，
那评论估计已经上万条了，
我看他第一天还是第二天，
就已经是八千多条评论了，
非常的炸裂啊，
所以湖南卫视还是非常非常会玩流量的，
那么当时呢，记者是先给他20分钟的时间，
让他去自由表演，
那么他呢就在稻田里面，
起着那辆非常破旧的摩托车啊，
去冲那个稻田的一个小土坡啊，
就是飞车表演冲坡表演，
但是呢他的意思就是这个车呢，
抓地力不太行，
那是记者就问他到底是车不行，
还是你的技术不行啊，
你要不还是再回去练一练啊，
我们先去别的城市去采访，
采访完了我们再回来，
是吧，他不行，
他就不放记者走，
就在里面不停的翘头也翘不起来，
冲破也冲不上去，
那么记者肯定是很失望啊，
对吧,
他本来是想拍一些很酷炫的镜头，
然后做一个选题，
结果发现其实这一天呢，
等于是被他忽悠过来，
就已经浪费时间了嘛，
但是呢当天晚上，
这个张雪就给记者就拼命的发消息，
意思就是说，
这是我的梦啊，
这是我的这个生活，
我的生活就是摩托车，
摩托车就是我的生活，
然后就拼命的想求他，
能不能再给一次机会，
我还要再去表演一次，
那么第二天呢，记者被他就是，
我觉得这对已经算是骚扰了，
骚扰的实在是没办法了，
那么第二天呢，记者就跟他见了一次面，
这个视频是全程都记录下来的，
记者跟他见面的时候，
第一句话其实态度非常的，
怎么讲呢，不友好，
当时是这么说的，
说你到底要干什么，
他是这么问的，
你到底要干什么，
就说明前一天晚上这个短信肯定是轰扎的，
轰扎的比较多的，
然后张雪就一年无辜的，
就说你能不能再拍我一次，
那么记者说不行，
非常坚决，不行，
为什么？
因为我要去100多公里外面去拍别人的采访，
已经约好了，
没有时间，
人家也是希望能够采访的时间更充裕一些，
那么张雪当时脑子钻在就非常的快，
他说那这样子吧，
我可以给你带个路，
我陪着你去，
对吧，100多公里，
我开着摩托车跟在你后面，
那么到了目的地了，
你正常该采访采访，
我也不打扰你，
等到你采访完了，
如果有空，
你能不能再拍我一下，
我再给你表演表演，
是吧,
那记者包括摄像，
司机肯定是劝他，
就你不要去了，
100多公里，
还有山路，
再看看那个摩托车，
对吧,
这个不管是你这个摩托车的，
性能行不行，
安全性行不行，
你就是跟着我在后面，
你想想看，
万一你要是出了点事情，
这记者是要担责任的，
这个记者也很有意思，
你在B站上面去找，
就是因为张雪这个事情活了以后，
然后这个记者就20年前采访他的，
他在吃饭的时候，
手机加在旁边，
他还聊了一下，
就是当年采访的整个过程，
我也找到这个视频的，
特别好玩，
他说当时我就很慌啊，
他一定要跟着我走，
我肯定是不想让他去的，
他说你想想看，
这个采访本身素材，
都已经没采完整，
就当时他觉得这个素材根本就沉不了片子，
已经浪费了一天时间，
你到时候万一要是再搭上个人命，
他是要负责任的，
那个哥们也挺有意思的，
一边吃饭一边聊，
长得好像明显比以前还要胖了一些了，
20年了,
你想想看，
张雪当年也是一个，
精神小伙长得挺瘦的，
有人说他长得像影镇啊，
有人讲，
但我觉得不像，
20年后的张雪现在肚子也有了，
长得脸也圆圆的了，
胖胖的了，
对不对，
那个记者也是长得，
有点胖，
有点发浮的样子了，
特别好玩，
就讲当年的这个事情，
那么张雪就是意思，
反正我就是坚持到底，
我就是希望你能不能再拍我一次，
就是他后来就成就了那句名言嘛，
对吧,
年轻人要有梦想，
你现在不去追梦，
你将来一定是会后悔的，
你哪怕就是失败，
你将来回头想一想，
只要你努力过，
你是不会后悔的，
其实,
现在很多人就是缺这个东西，
说白了，
脑子里面有千万个想法，
但是实际上身体他不执行，
你像张雪他可能没什么文化，
初中毕业对吧，
但是呢，
你会发现这个人，
他想法，
他不叫想法多，
他觉得这件事情大的方向是对的，
他就一定要去做，
只要这件事情他认准是对的，
就是他的底层逻辑是对的，
他就拼命的往前去闯，
去干,
哪怕是借钱，
哪怕吃再多的苦，
他绝对是对的，
一定要去干，
那么至于说一天干不成就两天，
两天干不成就三天，
你包括他当年跟凯月分手离开的时候，
其实很，
就是很正常的一个道理嘛，
就一脚就明白了，
那么凯月的合伙人，
其实说白了就是挣到了钱，
我们每一年啊去分分红，
也不用去搞那么极端的，
什么是赛事啊，
什么研发三缸发动机啊，
但是张雪的意思就是，
不行,
我要去干这个事情，
其实就这么简单一个事，
挣到了钱到底是把它分掉，
还是挣到了钱，
好比说挣了五千万，
你就已经开始考虑说，
后面怎么花掉一个亿了，
那作为你张雪的合伙人来讲，
我不想跟你这个疯子一起去拼命，
我们想按照正常的公司的运营模式，
每一年非脸钱可以股东，
然后大家一起过上好日子，
而你是不用去过好日子，
你可以用一个两千块钱的舅的手机，
你可以去不在乎穿什么名牌也好，
开什么好车也好，
张雪连汽车的驾照到今天都没有学，
记者问他，
说听说你没有汽车驾照，
他说对啊我没有，
问他为什么没有，
他的理由也很有意思，
他说我没有那么多完整的时间，
所以由此可见张雪忙到什么程度，
直播的时候我也听到张雪讲的这么一句话，
他说三百六十五天，
我完完整整休息的时间是不会超过十天，
我的铁太疯狂了，
这个哥们儿啊，
我觉得在我看那个叫乔布斯转的时候，
有一句话是这么讲的，
说乔布斯这个人啊，
他就像一束激光，
就是当他聚焦在这个点上的时候，
他得把它积穿，
但是激光的周围是一片黑暗，
一点光都没有，
那这个话是谁说的呢，
是乔布斯的妻子讲的，
其实言外之意啊，
我觉得大家懂得都懂了，
就是他聚焦的那个地方，
是能够积穿，
但是他的周围是一片黑暗，
还是还挺押韵的，
那张雪呢，
我觉得可能还不至于像到，
像马斯克呀，
乔布斯啊，
这种程度，
就是说什么亲情啊，
爱情这些东西，
我都可以不顾啊，
他我觉得他对他老婆应该挺好的，
对他的女儿，
我看他有个视频，
带着他女儿骑着摩托车，
就很明显他女儿对他爸爸的那种，
脸上一直的那种喜悦，
他应该，
虽然说可能陪伴家人的时间不多，
但是他应该，
在家庭的这种关系处理方面来讲的话，
有他那种爱的表达是，
是不会藏于内心的，
就是我爱你就是爱你，
我喜欢你就是表达出来那种感觉，
你跟他这种人处是很轻松的，
非常轻松的，
那么我们就回到这个记者采访很有意思，
然后呢，
他第二次采访呢，
也也顺利的实现了啊，
记者也是，
我觉得这个记者的人也非常的好，
我当时也发了一个微博，
我说在，
20年后的今天，
还能不能会有这样的一个，
不叫记者吧，
叫新闻工作者啊，
有没有这样的一种人，
还愿意去为这么一个，
你觉得根本就，
微乎其微，
就几乎就是万分之一，
可能10万分之一，
才有可能成为，
职业采访手的，
这么一个，
村子里面的，
小镇上的，
一个修理工，
修摩托车的，
这样的一个人，
为他的梦想，
去付出你的，
这么一个热门节目的，
一党专题，
一党选题，
你愿不愿意，
我觉得现在我估计很多的媒体，
不一定愿意，
当然你把它当个乐子，
当一个这个话题去炒作一下，
这有可能，
但是你说发自内心愿不愿意，
应该是不会愿意的，
当时的这个记者，
后来就是20年后的那一段，
他自己的这个回忆啊，
他是这么讲的，
他说这条片子，
我拿回去之后，
我自己当时都觉得，
台里面不一定能通过，
但是他最后触动他的是什么，
就是,
张雪第二次表演，
其实表演的也不好，
也不好，
就无非最后有几个镜头，
什么人躺在摩托车上，
对吧,
什么这个，
单脚啊，
双手拖把，
这个双手拖把，
说句实在话，
我骑个电动自行车，
我也能双手拖把，
但是他说我不主张啊，
我不主张啊，
但他那些表演呢，
就有点悉松平常了，
但是记者看到他在，
做各种这些，
在泥地里面摔跤啊，
就是各种动作，
那当然下着雨嘛，
然后浑身都灵透了，
脸上也都是被雨水打的，
也是红红通通的，
然后他也不喊疼，
云南白要往我身上喷，
还继续表演，
就是人看到最后，
看到那种场景，
他是会被感动的，
记者看到最后，
觉得这小伙子不是说，
就是一个就是嫩头青，
就是想上电视，
想要获得名气，
他可能真的就是想被，
想被车队看到，
他真的是想抓住这一次机会，
改变自己的命运，
19岁啊,
兄弟们啊，
你看我经常在一起打球，
小伙子他们喊我输，
我说你别喊输，
你喊哥，
回来我被我老婆骂一顿嘛，
说你看人家18岁，
有的可能18岁都不到的孩子，
在你的面前喊你一声输，
不很正常吗，
你为什么还逼着人家喊你哥，
我现在想想看19岁，
真的是一个非常年轻的年龄，
19岁今年，
是哪一年啊，
2026年19岁,。
是07年差不多吧，
2026、07、19,。
差不多，
07年出生的，
很小很小啊，
如果是今年来讲19岁的孩子，
他为了追梦，
而且他本身就没有人脉，
没有机会，
在那个环境里面，
抓住了这个电视台的机会，
他肯定是想尽一些办法，
对吧，去表现，
当时其实包括他们司机啊，
其实包括摄像都已经很不舒服了，
因为大家也是零字语，
你在那边拍，
是不是，
那你拍不出什么素材啊，
你拍来拍去，
你这个冲撲什么，
一个也没表扬成功，
但是他就觉得小伙子很有韧性，
最后这个主持人提了个建议，
就是说这样子吧，
这个视频呢，
我们最后收个尾，
就是去看一看，
就是你的家，
因为我们前面讲他不是离异嘛，
他离异了就是他跟他奶奶住，
然后就去他奶奶家，
其实先拍了这个张雪的家，
张雪也是就像我们，
有没有人在那种路边的修理场见过，
我以前在路边修理场，
跟老板关系处得比较好，
有的时候拿一些什么东西啊，
老板说来上楼，
我带你拿，
那我去楼上一看我就发现，
其实跟我想象中的那种状态很像，
因为他根本就没有时间打理，
每一天手上都是油屋，
他一楼是举身机啊，
换轮胎啊，
这些就是有的大部分的修理场，
其实我觉得都不是特别干净啊，
但是有一些处理的还可以，
但是像他们这种，
一楼如果是修理，
二楼如果是住人的话，
你去看他二楼的房间，
那真的就是只能说是有一个占落脚的地方，
然后那个床铺也没，
他也没收拾，
就是那种很乱的感觉，
那么征学的当时住的地方就是这样，
但是让这个记者感动的最关键的点是去他奶奶家，
因为他是跟他奶奶过的嘛，
他奶奶家他一见面就把他奶奶就把他抱起来很开心，
而且还有个细节就是他都里面一共三百块钱，
他给摩托车加油花了四十块钱，
然后给他奶奶买这个营养品花了两百块钱，
就是记者当时的原话啊，
所以我也是在讲嘛，
就他这个人的性格从这些细节你就能看得出来，
那么当时看到他奶奶家，
他奶奶家情况也是很一般嘛，
就是家里面一穷二百，
那他就能深刻的感觉到，
这小伙子就是想通过这一档节目，
去曝光一下自己，
让车队看到改变自己的命运，
后来呢这个记者也说到了，
就是他们当时去审节目的时候，
台长都根本连看都没怎么看，
就是没关心这个选题，
根本就不会想到这个选题会火，
但是后来这个片子也是被播出去了嘛，
就台里面也审核通过了嘛，
一审二审三审，
然后播出去了，播出去之后，
记者是这么说的，
他说接到了大量的电话，
在网上反响非常好，
然后那个时候他不能叫网上，
就是在电视台播出去之后，
效果非常的好，
效果非常好呢，
打电话过来的很多的观众，
很多都是女性，
很多都是女生，
看到之后非常感动，
说其中有一个女生，
本来是准备自杀的，
因为她抑郁症嘛，
但是看到她之后，
她发现这个世界上竟然有人，
就是比她还要惨，
日子过得比她还要惨，
但是她的内心竟然那么的阳光，
而且就是非常执着的去追自己的梦想，
所以那个女孩说，
既然都有她这样的一个人做榜样了，
那我就不自杀了，
那就好好地活吧，
对吧，没有什么坎实过不去的，
那么这个节目播出之后呢，
也是让张雪得赏所愿，
车队也是看到了她，
而把她招进了这个塞车圈，
我觉得车队也是蛮闲的，
晚上没事也回去看一看，
这个湖南卫视的晚间新闻，
但是我个人猜测，
她应该不是上来就当塞车手，
她应该是先在车队里面打砸，
然后慢慢的一步一步地开上这个车，
或者要骑上这个摩托，
那么很多故事其实写到这呢，
应该就会来一句说，
啊这个命运的齿轮就开始转动了，
但是你仔细想一想，
其实张雪后来的一些经历，
你要放到今天看，
你会发现她这个人的命运，
不是说齿轮开始慢慢转动了，
而是她用她的肩膀顶着这个齿轮往前走，
甚至于这个齿轮不转了，
她就去跑别的地方去转别的齿轮去了，
这根本很有韧性啊，
那么她进入拆车圈呢，
也不代表说她的人身就又上台阶，
实现梦想，
然后就功成名就，
恰恰相反，
她其实进入这个摩托车的圈子之后会发现，
她的天花板是很低的，
她后来也承认了，
就是说按照她的这个，
就是我们讲一下，
不知道是叫静态天赋，
还是动态天赋，
就是她是很难成为顶级的职业摩托车手的，
不是因为说她不够拼，
也不是因为她不热爱，
而是因为这个职业赛事啊，
就这件事情你光是有一枪热血没有用，
你不仅仅要有天赋，
你还要要有这种后天的努力，
你要烧钱，
吃资源，
吃体力，
去不停的练习，
要找好的教练，
甚至包括要找好的车队，
所以她不是没有实力，
也不是没有成绩，
问题是，
她确确实是天花板很低，
她钱也没钱，
资源也没资源，
甚至于她还有一些伤病，
所以慢慢的她就发现这件事情，
你单纯一腔情愿想要去当车手，
你可能最后你连养活自己都很难，
你别说养活自己老婆一家子了，
所以这条路就非常难走，
那么很多人的人生其实，
真正决定后面能不能成啊，
她不是在你吃最大的苦的时候，
而是当你第一次发现说，
哎,
就是我好像有些事情是真的做不到，
就是你当触摸到，
或者说看到自己的天花板的时候，
这个时候，
就可能出现两种情况，
第一个有些人就认命了，
与其这样就不如躺平吧，
但是我觉得躺平这个词是分两块来讲的，
前两天知识星球也有人问我这个问题，
说AI这个时代即将到来，
我们应该如何面对，
是不是就应该彻底躺平，
我说,
其实躺和平是两个动作，
躺是你的行为上，
就彻底我不执行了，
我不干了，就这样了，
停滞不前了，
而平其实指的是一种心态，
就是我的心态很平淡很平和，
我觉得躺倒不至于，
我们还是要挣扎一下，努力一下，
磨练一下，
这里面毕竟还是有机会的，
让自己最起码不是说完全不被淘汰，
晚一点淘汰吧，
人类早晚还是要被机器淘汰掉的，
对不对，
在我的专业领域，
我至少能够打败，
我不讲99%，打败一般以上的人，
就是既是淘汰前面50%的人，
你至少到了55%还没到我呢，
还没轮到我呢，
我是60%以后嘛，
是不是，
所以我说，
第一个躺你就不要完全躺，
还是要努力一点，
第二个平，
那这个就看个人了，
心态的调整就一定要平，
一定要平淡，
一定要平静，
一定要平和，
当然这不是鸡汤啊，
因为我本身我就是这样子的人，
虽然说我打不到像就是张雪那样纯粹，
但是我心里面其实我很清楚，
很多的一些就是物质上的东西啊，
就是我需要，
我能买得起的我就买，
而且大家经常讲我金流刀，
对吧,
我自己也说我是金流刀，
有些东西我觉得，
该不用去花这个冤枉钱的，
就不用去花，
能用就行，
但有些东西要用好的，
我一定是直接一步到位嘛，
对吧,
所以有些人其实到了这个行业里面，
他就觉得天花板已经看到了，
我就认了，
觉得就行了吧，
就这样吧，
天赋也就这样，
家地也就这样，
命也就这样，
但是张雪没有，
张雪他其实看到自己天花板，
但他不是难受，
他是,
我换个想法，
我换个思路，
我曲线救国，
我绕一下行不行，
我既然摩托车，
我骑不到最前面，
那我能不能造一辆摩托车，
让别人骑到最前面，
所以一不小心就骑到了，
这个世界级三世的第一名嘛，
所以你看，
有的时候，
就是当这个念头一旦出来，
你的人生可能就开始发生改变了，
这就是我一直在提的，
就是提升认知，
那么他虽然没什么文化，
但他不代表没什么见识，
他就算没什么见识，
但他不代表没什么常识，
我一直讲的嘛，
就是你的文化知识，
常识，见识这些东西，
其实都要提升，
这也是为什么，
你看我身边有些家长，
他为了让孩子的分数显著的提高，
会把他送到很多的一些，
小县城里面去读书，
因为那些小县城里面，
他那种教学模式，
那就是完全耍体，
上期节目还是上上期，
我提到小镇作题家那个比喻，
好多人说你不了解小镇作题家，
然后你这个比喻不好，
那再次我给大家道歉，
那我相信肯定也是，
有一些兄弟，
对吧他们是在小镇是靠，
这个做提议或者是考分，
然后呢上了好学校，
这个呢确确实实，
就是你如果，
如果我不是从小镇作题家走出来的，
那我也没有资格去评价，
也没有资格拿他去做比喻，
再次呢跟大家表示道歉啊，
但是今天我不知道为什么，
说着说着又说到这个点上了，
就是如果说孩子如果往小县城里去送，
因为我身边就有南京的，
父母把孩子往比方说南通啊，
或者是往泰州下面的江燕啊去送，
因为里面都有非常好的学校，
但是我不太主张，
因为他的这个分数可能上去了，
他可能是考上一个好的学校了，
但是第一个他要接受的是住宿，
跟父母的这几年，
三年初中三年高中六年的分离，
那么第二一个就是他，
怎么讲的就是他可能在见识，
在认知方面，
他离开了南京这个大城市，
他所社交的这些朋友，
他所谈论的这些话题，
他的童年，
他处在的这个环境就完全跟在南京不一样，
当然了，
这个我不是说南京好，
小县城不好，
那南通的兄弟肯定要讲了，
我们南通有些地方比南京还要好，
还要强，
那我也是认可的对吧，
那居住环境各方面肯定你有你的特色，
但是总体来讲城市，
他还是要分一线准一线，
大城市小城市，
这个肯定是西威的一些差别，
你可能在当时当下你体现不出来，
但是你在往后他的某些行为局旨方面，
你就明显能发现这个人是从北上往出来的，
大城市出来的，
还是小县城出来的，
但是我从来没有任何的，
就是说怎么讲的，
就是有人讲叫做什么，
就是城市比比试链，
或者说是叫做挑拨城市之间的对立，
没有这个概念，
就是从小孩的教育层面上来讲，
其实我是不主张的，
就是你既然能在南京找一所学校去上，
那你就上吧，
那为什么一定要为了分数去往这种低县城市去放孩子，
把他安排在一个技术的学校里面，
当然每个家长有自己的想法，
想法不同，
我们尊重别人的命运，
没什么好评价的，
但是只是我的个人的想法，
那么提到张雪那也是一样的道理嘛，
就是张雪他面对自己的这个命运，
在这个小县城里面，
他父母也离异也不怎么管了，
那么奶奶肯定也给他不了什么建议，
那他这种生命力他是有任性的，
他对于自己的这种命运的掌握，
他有一种任性，
这条路子不了，
我就换嘛，
对不对，
摩托车我竟然骑不到最前面，
那我能不能造一辆车，
让别人替我骑到最前面，
哎，我换个思路嘛，
但是这个很明显对于他来讲，
也不是那么容易实现的，
造摩托车你开什么玩笑，
当塞车手，
你的已经摸到天花板了，
难道说造摩托车你摸不到天花板吗，
有些人可能想的不敢想，
其实说白了，
他这个梦想只是稍微拐了个弯，
原先他追的是速度本身，
但是后来他追的就变成了制造速度的能力，
不就是这么简单一个事嘛，
那么后来张学为了去造车，
那首先你要去进工厂里面，
你打螺丝嘛，
对吧,
你不是说说造就造，
你要知道整个的摩托车，
这一套的制造体系是怎么来的，
所以他你看，
之前的经历，
就有点像是在江湖里面去混的人，
但是现在他要进厂打螺丝了，
对吧,
他开始进入到一个正规的体系里面了，
那么他开始去像个学生一样，
张尔巴你去学习了，
他更多的是要在工厂里面，
从一个使用者的角度，
改装者的角度，
塞车手的角度，
他去了解，
去摸索，
去体系的，
就整个的体系化的，
去知道这台车从构想到设计，
从零件到总程，
从结构到量产，
他到底是怎么一步一步去落地的，
那么张学这个人呢，
后来进到工厂之后也没老实，
那么他自己也讲了一个故事嘛，
他说我在工厂里面脾气不是很好，
对吧,
那可能同事领导也不太喜欢我，
那么他说同事也好，
领导也好，
甚至连这个工厂的老板，
他也都怼了个遍，
但是你要知道，
就是张学这个人的性格啊，
他是对事不对人，
就是你要跟这个人处事，
你知道他的性格之后，
你会发现他每次发火，
一定是这个事情做的不对，
而不是说你这个人的性格，
你这个人的脾气，
你这个人说话的方式，
我很讨厌，
我不喜欢，
不是这样子的，
所以呢，
只要稍微开明一点的这个人啊，
情商高一点的人，
跟他相处的话，
很轻松的，
那么他当时讲那个故事，
就是说领导不认同他的一个方案，
那么他嘴上先不跟领导吵，
他也知道你这个关高一级，
或者这个只为高一级压死人吗，
他嘴上不讲，
好，转头，
别人中午休息了，
他不休息，
他利用午休两个小时，
他去手搓一个模型，
他把这个模型给他手搓出来之后，
他就直接让领导，
你上手试一试，
你看一看，
我说的对不对就完了嘛，
对吧,
领导后来上手一摸一发现，
他真的是有一些差别，
那么最后呢，
就按照张雪的方式来去做了，
这他自己口述的一个故事，
因为陈浅之前也采访过这个张雪，
大家在网上搜一搜陈浅，
就那个陈浅的朋友圈嘛，
陈浅采访他，
那么其实这个细节就很像。
武侠小说里面的那种人，
就是嘴硬，
脾气大，
不会绕弯子，
但是他手上，
他真的有活，
所以我跟你讲，
就学好一门技能啊，
你饿不死人，
去哪都能油碗饭吃，
那么也就是从这个时候开始，
那么你就会发现张雪已经不是那个，
只靠自己的感觉去骑车的人，
他开始慢慢的开始对车的直觉，
他翻译成了一种叫工程语言，
因为你看他之前的经历，
是从修理工，
然后到一个车队里面的，
不管是打砸的也好，
还是成为车手也好，
跑赛道也好，
然后再去进工厂，
他这段经历其实对他的整个的人生啊，
他的经验的丰富程度啊，
他是会这个人生越来越厚重，
专业度也是越来越丰富，
所以我不讲嘛，
就是我是一直建议年轻人啊，
如果你大学毕业了，
在一个行业里面，
你一定要选准方向，
哪怕这是一个，
我们讲个不好听的，
就是可能挣不到钱的行业，
甚至于是一个西洋的产业，
但是你即使在这个产业里面，
你熬,
你熬个10年、20年，
你也是成为一个老妖怪了，
你手上掌握的专业技能，
以及你这个行业里的人脉资源，
也足够你，
我不能说是躺平吧，
就足够你这一辈子，
吃喝不愁了，
除非是真的是这个行业，
也是拉垮的一塌糊涂，
完完全全，
这个行业所有的人都是哀鸿遍野，
这种行业，
我就不知道现在是哪个行业了，
但是,
但凡不是这种行业，
我觉得你干个20年，
你是个老妖怪，
肯定是过得比较滋润的，
那么,
很多人就喜欢把这种，
像张雪江的一个，
就是吊斯逆袭的人，
把他再塑造成一个什么天才，
比方说从小的时候，
就喜欢拆家里面的这些，
什么收音机、电视机，
从小就对机械有天赋，
我觉得未必，
未必啊，
他真的成功之后了，
你写这些故事，
只是为了他的这个人物传记，
更加的有故事性，
或者是色彩更加的浓郁一些，
但是,
我觉得他对于张雪这个人来讲，
只能说脑子稍微比较活一点，
然后呢比较的直扭，
比较的一根筋，
但是他我怎么看的，
我觉得都不像是一种，
就是从小就会有天赋，
然后去天生就是造车的，
玩机械的，
不至于，
我觉得不至于，
只是讲，
这个哥们可能很早就已经醒悟过来了，
就是摩托车是自己的爱好，
然后这一辈子，
如果想抓住一次人生翻身的机会，
很有可能就是在摩托车这个行业里面，
也只有这个行业，
他有热爱，
他愿意花两倍、十倍的努力，
他不是有一句话也是这么讲的吗，
那我比别人付出了两倍，
甚至十倍的努力，
那为什么这个最终的成功的人不是我呢，
他就应该是我，
就是我，
他反复强调的积蓄，
我觉得这哥们，
每次一讲话，
就像打了这个鸡血一样的，
很有这种王感，
他就适合在目前这个互联网的时代，
让他火，
再加上现在他又有这种，
十打十的这种，
我们不管是从实体产业上来讲，
还是从拿到了这种世界级的冠军来讲，
那这种你想光环，
我觉得在任何的，
你就是在武侠小说里面，
你在这种玄幻的小说里面，
他这种人物，
那绝对也是往那面一放的话，
那江湖的这种地位也好，
还是实际的这种战斗力也好，
那都是报表的，
对吧，都绝对是报表的，
所以这个过程其实一点我觉得都不浪漫，
也不适合拍成什么这种热血的，
这种什么网剧之类的，
不是有人讲说应该把张雪的片子拍成，
非是人生四嘛，
说下次非是人生四，
让他和隐征两个人去野，
男主角就是他嘛，
但是我觉得没有必要，
因为你真的把它变成爽闻的男主角，
甚至把它开始进行小说话，
故事话去改写，
对他来讲是伤害，
我觉得真的对张雪本人来讲是伤害，
这个人就算是定力再强，
如果周围一圈人都在拍他的马屁，
那么最终他往往在决策方面很容易也会有失误，
因为他手上以前是，
就是我们讲，
就是当你保持一定的饥饿感的时候，
你人是会很清醒的，
你永远知道你的目的性是什么，
但是如果说你手边的资源，
你要钱给钱，要人给人，
要资源给资源，
这也是为什么富二代往往创业不成功的原因，
他没有饥饿感，
他干任何事情，
他有的是钱，
亏一点亏一点也无所谓，
那这个我再讲个小故事给大家听，
我们家门口开这个面馆，
然后有一天又刚过完年嘛，
我看那个面馆，
这个门头也不是很显眼，
那个门头那四个字叫什么，
引什么什么面啊，
就那个门头那几个字，
那个面条的面好像还是个反体字，
就完全就不像是个张尔巴顶开面馆的，
一般开面馆的就是什么，
什么老张面馆，
什么锤子面馆，
地雷面馆，
张寡夫面馆，
这一听就知道了，
很接地气，
他那个面馆一看就不是这种样子，
进去之后呢，
店里面只有一个人啊，
一个中年的大叔吧，
我管他叫大叔，
应该估计可能50岁左右吧，
那么他当时就一个人嘛，
我在这儿老婆两个人，
我们三个人就一边吃一边聊天，
他说这个面馆呢，
是一个之前做房地产的老板，
就是老板有很多门面房，
应该就财富自由了嘛，
他就特别爱吃，
那么他呢就想当时这个门面房，
这个门面房就是这个搞房地产的老板，
买的其中一间，
他控制也控制嘛，
当时他就，
也是因为吃面条认识了这个厨师，
跟我聊天的是厨师，
说我们一起合伙来做面馆，
但这个厨师呢，
他原来是做的这种红暗，
他会烧菜，
但是他不一定会虾面，
然后这个时候呢，
这个厨师又引荐了一个，
这个女孩是当年做这个海外的，
叫做导游，
就是国际旅行团的导游，
因为这个疫情那几年嘛，
就是他们就挣不到钱了，
然后这个女孩就开始转做微商，
然后这个女孩也特别爱吃，
女孩是内蒙人，
然后她呢就学了一首这个，
应该就是相当于是叫老鲁面啊，
发现就是这种什么炸熏鱼啊，
什么扣肉啊，
反正她就是，
懂得怎么去运营嘛，
当然了就是也知道这个面条怎么好吃，
那么这三个人在一起，
就是凑在一起，
相当于开这个面馆，
那么请问这个面馆，
你觉得能做长久吗？
我其实不是特别的看好，
我当时当着她面我就跟她讲了，
我说这个面馆呢，
其实你们三个人肯定是这么想的，
对吧,
这个做微商的女老板呢，
相当于会做运营，
这个店由她来打理，
然后呢，
这个房东呢，
就相当于拿房子入股，
对吧,
她也不投钱，
然后这个房子就房租免了，
然后你作为这个厨师来讲的话，
你肯定考虑的就是说，
我每个月十的多少钱，
你等于就是拿了一份工资，
你当工作来干，
那么这个提供门面房的老板呢，
是赔二不赔的，
只要不亏钱就带着玩玩，
你呢是拿工资的，
那个女的相当于店长呢，
其实是这二八你想把她当成事业来做的，
然后我当着问了一句话，
我说这个店有没有女老板还干别的事情，
她就说你可以加她微信，
墙上有微信，
我扫了一下我一看，
她的微商也没有丢，
她的朋友圈里面还是在卖各种各样的一些什么保健品啊，
什么面膜啊之类的东西，
所以她也不是这一件事情是主业，
我说你们三个人在一起干，
每个人都有各自的索求，
也有各自的想法，
也有各自其他的事情，
只有你一个人是当工作来干的，
那也就是个工作，
仅此而已嘛，
对吧,
有别人挖更高的薪水你就直接走了，
那么你们三个错在一起之后，
你们算的这笔账，
就是每个月是只要钱进账，
我就是赚钱，
实际上这个逻辑是错的，
因为当这个做房地产的老板，
他有一天突然发现，
其实我那么辛苦，
我都不如把这个门面房租出去，
我哪怕低一点，
我租出去，
我一年就是稳稳的收租子的钱，
也比我辛苦辛苦干这么多年，
这个饭店的钱真的不讲多吧，
真的还稳一些，
对不对，
当这个店如果经营的不是特别的好，
投入产出比不一样，
就是没有达到预期，
然后分的钱最后大家也不是很满意，
那个做微商的那个女的，
女生，女店长，
他也不愿意啊，
我花了一些精力，
我还不如去卖卖这个面膜，
真的还比这个多呢，
对不对，
所以你们三个人在一起，
年性非常的弱，
没有共同的梦想，
就是你们形成这个组织啊，
它很松散，
很松散，
所以有的时候为什么，
要高度的意识上的统一呢，
其实这个做思想工作的人很重要啊，
就一定要意识上统一，
嘿嘿嘿，
所以跟他简单聊了一下，
那其实讲这个故事，
也是一样的道理嘛，
就是张雪这个人身上就有这种，
他能让身边的人，
一起去跟他为了一个梦想去追逐，
我看到他很多的视频都是这样子的，
对吧,
给这个工程师放假，
带他们去国外旅游，
给他们发红包，
告诉他我们这个企业将来要做到中国的，
比方做前三啊，
全球的，
可能前八还是前七，
他的梦想也没有那么夸张，
但是呢，
大家跟着他一起干，
而且现在十打十的也拿出成绩来了，
那很多人也就知道了，
跟着他一起，
有可能能实现这个梦想，
对不对，
所以这个邻居率是非常强的，
好,
我们刚刚讲是进攻上打螺丝了嘛，
那么打了一段时间螺丝之后呢，
他就发现啊，
其实这也不是他想要的，
他最终还是想要去造这个摩托车，
后来呢，
他就去了重庆，
那么重庆这个城市呢，
很有意思，
因为他，
用张雪的话来讲的话，
为什么选重庆，
因为重庆，
整个的摩托车的产业链，
在这个地方是非常完整的，
这个我觉得就有点像电子的行业在深圳啊，
在深圳的话，
上午苹果出了一个新品，
可能深圳下午就出了一个，
华强北的版本啊，
长得一模一样的是吧，
所以他到深圳之后呢，
他就想怎么怎么能去自己去造车，
那么他一开始的这个方式呢，
我觉得是比较的，
就是切肉点，
相对来讲会简单，
或者说是入手的难度，
会稍微的轻一点，
就是做组装车，
改装车，
然后在线上卖，
这段经历他当时，
接受采访的时候也说过，
他当时就是买来一些就是，
正常的量产车型，
然后根据他的想法，
他觉得这个地方不好，
那个地方不合适，
他来做改装，
然后在线上把他的整个改装的过程，
都发布出去了，
就是当这台车都还没完工的时候，
甚至于到后来就是，
他只是提了个想法，
就已经有人开始附定金了，
所以他当时如果按照这条路往下走，
他也能挣到钱，
就是他在摩托车的改装圈子里面，
我估猜，
应该很多年前就已经很有名了，
所以他当时不是讲了吗，
说做改装当时第一笔挣了50万，
挣了50万之后，
马上立刻又投入进去了，
继续开始去做其他的下一批的改装，
因为他要定配件，
有各种各样的要采购，
都是要花钱的嘛，
他这个里面，
我觉得也是个重资产的一个产业，
也需要去垫很多的资金，
那么如果按照这条路去往下走呢，
就不敢说做成一个什么，
摩托车工厂的老板，
但是起码做一个改装摩托车的小老板，
肯定是没有问题的，
这连小钱过过小日子，
那么直到有一天他发现，
他的改装的案例，
开始有一些大厂，
开始模仿他了，
就是他自己没有工厂是手搓的嘛，
那有些大厂开始模仿他，
就讲白了就是直接山寨，
直接抄嘛，
那么很多人遇到这种事情，
第一反应肯定是生气，
打官司，
上网,
怼,
因为相当于就是偷了你的这样的一个原创，
但是张雪的反应很简单，
他看到别人模仿了，
他马上意识到，
如果是今后我去走这条路，
组装,
改装,
捣腾,
这个事情是没有必累的，
迟早谁都能学会，
那怎么办呢？
那就只能再换一个赛道，
对吧,
你抄我的拼装，
那我就做设计，
你抄我的设计，
那我就去研发发动机，
总之呢，
就是他不愿意在一个别人很容易抄的这个位置上停留太久，
但是这个讲起来容易做起来也很难，
他当时研发了一款车叫自由嘛，
他研发这个自由，
说前前后后花了一百多万，
但是现在回头来看的话，
他说那是一次非常不合格的开发，
为什么？
因为一百多万，
这个钱实在是太少了，
只能用很低端，
很低端的供应链，
讲白了都是用一些劣质的这些零部件嘛，
然后很多的供应商，
还不愿意跟他合作，
因为他实在是没有钱，
一百多万对于，
你要造一个开发一个原创的车，
实在是太难了。
那么因为张雪，
他是常连在摩托车这个圈子里面，
对吧,
又是论坛发帖，
又是帮这个车油改装，
那么自然有些小名气，
后来他就遇到了两位合伙人，
就一起创立了凯乐机车，
那么听到这儿，
大家就知道了，
相当于他已经开始正规的公司化的去运作了，
什么叫做正规的公司化运作呢？
就是你想打造一个量产的摩托车，
那么这里面，
一家公司里面，
你得要有相应的供应链，
你要有市场的部门，
有经销商的渠道，
那背后肯定是要有投资人嘛，
对吧,
用资本去运作，
那么整体的传播节奏，
你得要是有一套非常专业的人去操作，
所以这个对他来讲，
就是当时我看张雪接受采访的时候，
提到一个词叫做训练，
他说在凯乐的创业的这几年当中，
是对他的一个全方位的训练，
他是反过来的一个视角，
其实很多的企业家都是在讲，
我们是怎么怎么做企业的，
但是他反过来讲说，
是因为这个企业对他，
有了一个全方位的训练，
所以这哥们有的时候，
思路真的只有他的角度上来，
你才能去理解，
你要如果换作任何一个人，
你会觉得他的这种回答问题，
虽然很直接，
但你可能还真不太能get到，
他这个回答问题背后的这个逻辑，
那么凯乐的首款设定上市，
其实卖得就非常的好，
很多经销商那边提货都要排队，
那么按照正常的商业逻辑，
那么到了这一步，
那相当于就是第一桶金就挖到了嘛，
挣到钱了嘛，
是不是，
那最合理的操作是什么，
就应该是多再去开发一些走量的车型，
把这个盘子尽量的做大，
把这个钱先给挣了，
那所有人也是劝这个公司这些领导就这么去干的，
但是张雪当时的反应不是这样子的，
所以就是我刚刚前面提到的，
这也是他和他的合伙人，
为什么会有那么大的分歧，
最后选择离开，
就是他要自主研发那个三缸发动机，
因为张雪认为三缸发动机可以兼顾两缸的低扭，
以及四缸的高转速，
而且他的轻量化非常的好，
但是这个三缸发动机，
他跟汽车上的三缸机其实是一样的道理，
就是他的震动控制特别的难，
他的点火顺序因为是基础的，
所以你要解决震动的问题，
你需要去给他做调教，
你需要去研发怎么去抑制震动，
所以整个的费用是非常的高，
这也是为什么很多的摩托车的品牌，
他不愿意去投入去研发这个三缸发动机的原因，
说白了就是东西是个好东西，
大家都知道这条路线是可以选的，
但是砸了那么多的钱，
你最终把这么个好东西放到市场上，
有没有人认啊，
对他的合伙人肯定也会拿汽车圈去举例子，
说张选你看一看汽车圈里面那些三缸机，
别客用三缸，企业最后亏了多少钱，
福特用三缸，福克斯都停产了，
其他的所有的品牌哪怕就是混合动力车型，
用三缸机当成增成器，老百姓都不认，
我怀疑可能他们开会的时候，
合伙人都是这么讲的，
说汽车圈是血淋淋的教训，
你现在还在摩托车里面搞三缸，
你搞什么搞的，有什么好搞的呢？
对不对，两缸的老百姓用用不就行了吗？
你要大排量搞搞四缸的不就行了吗？
搞什么三缸的，
你现成都能用，
你为什么要用什么原创的自主的，
但你要知道一点，
他的思路，张雪的思路跟合伙人不一样，
张雪是赛车手是他的第一梦想，
他是赛车出身，
他的所有的逻辑就是三缸将来在赛道上面，
一定是能干翻那些其他的车型，
他是按照这个逻辑去做的，
但是合伙人的逻辑是商业逻辑，
其实都没有错，
大家都没有错，
就这个事情太贵，
而且坐起来太慢，
太费钱，
将来可能把这个企业就拖到离台里面，
最后资金链断裂，
我不能是把这个企业绑定到你个人的梦想，
然后一起去就开一个车子，
没有刹车就往海里追，
对不对，
那张雪你问他说，
你未来什么时候企业能挣钱，
你现在企业还是亏钱的，
对吧,
他也没什么能说得上来的东西，
他说我现在确实今年，
好比说我挣了5000万，
但是我已经想到明年一个亿怎么花了，
当然他也没挣到5000万，
我明天看到数据说张雪的去年的财报是亏了2000万，
但他觉得已经很好了，
第一年还是第二年，
2024年应该是第二年，
第三年，
已经是亏了2000万还算不错了，
现在又有融资进来了嘛，
是不是，
所以张雪当时在凯越是被，
不能叫被贬吧，
就是从总经理最后调整到这个叫做技术研发的副总裁，
副总监，
但是他当时提出自己的想法之后，
就是合伙人都不同意，
那他就说那你不同意，
我就出来我就自己单干，
那么他还发了一条朋友圈嘛，
在2024年的3月份，
张雪朋友圈就官宣自己离开了一手创办的凯越，
那么在4月份的时候，
他又开始官宣，
创立了以自己名字命名的品牌叫张雪机车，
所以你看，
你听张雪这个人的故事啊，
我觉得很有启发，
但是他这条路不一定能模仿，
因为你可能第一个，
你没有他的这种基础的环境，
什么叫做基础的环境呢，
我曾经讲过，
一个人想要一无反顾的去创业，
你得要三无，
叫无财，无德，无根，
什么意思呢，
我说的不一定对，
但你可以听一听有没有道理啊，
那么无财就是你兜里没有钱，
一穷二百，
你本身就是个光脚的，
不怕穿鞋的了，
你就可以完全是放手一搏嘛，
那么无德不是只说，
你没有道德，
而是要像张雪这样子，
就是你为了达到目的，
也不能叫不择手段吧，
就是最起码你要有任性，
一次一次这个失败，
劈头盖脸的往你的身上去砸的时候，
你不要感到沮丧，
你要觉得说失败是正常的，
失败才是常规我要遇到的情况，
而成功那是一次偶然，
哎，你要有这种叫做逆伤，
那这种我讲叫做无德，
就无德就是别人看这个人很傻，
这个人很蠢，
这个人甚至就死皮赖脸，
就是个无奈，
但是你管他无奈不无奈的，
对不对，
只要你不尴尬，
尴尬就是别人，
你在张雪的身上就能充分的体现，
那么第三个叫无根，
无根是什么意思呢，
我本身也不想回我的老家了，
对吧,
他父母也离异了，
他没有什么家庭的这种牵绊，
那我去哪儿都一样，
我去世界的任何一个角落，
那都是我的家，
哪里适合我，
哪里有资源我就去哪儿，
对不对，
他可以从小县城直接去到市区去淮化，
他也可以直接从小市区去到浙江，
他在这个摩托车厂领罗斯，
我查了一下资料，
应该是在浙江的一个工厂去领罗斯，
然后我想去造车，
我要搞改装，
我就去重庆，
每个人，
每个兄弟你想一想，
你的人生能这样子随意的切换吗，
想去哪儿就去哪儿，
想到哪儿工作就哪儿工作，
甚至还带着老婆一起去，
你觉得有可能吗，
我曾经讲过我有的一段创业经历，
那我那家公司其实到后来。
也是被阿里收购了，
但是到收购的那个时候。
已经跟我没什么关系了，
这是很熟悉我，
很熟悉的我，
这个朋友身边的朋友，
知道这段经历，
那么我去到杭州的时候，
2015年,
我刚落脚，
还真准备创业的，
家里面就遇到了一些小变故，
对吧,
那么同时，
其实媳妇也是极力不愿意，
我去杭州的，
我当时讲了一句话，
我就是说，
哎呀没关系嘛，
我就在这边拼个两三年，
对吧,
有个对赌协议，
两三年之后，
那说不定就财富自由了嘛，
那媳妇的意思是，
不行,
因为孩子还小，
孩子才两三岁，
你去到杭州，
你能保证什么时候回来吗，
我说我每一周，
周末我一定能回来，
他说不可能，
想都不用想，
那么结果也确实是这样子的，
一个月能保证回来一趟，
最多两趟就不得了了，
为什么，
我当时跟合伙人讲的也是，
我说我周末一定要回家，
他说可以的，
没问题，
都能接受，
但是等到，
星期五的晚上，
通知你说投资人，
星期六过来要开个会，
星期天投资人约一起吃个饭，
那么约的那些一桌子上面的那些人，
都是大佬，
很多的一些人，
可能你甚至于在，
网上这个新闻，
这些这个，
很多反正我就不说名字了，
你都见过的，
那你也是难得就这么一次机会，
能跟他们近距离的相处，
你说你是留还是不留，
如果是星期天的晚上吃饭，
难道说星期五的晚上回到南京，
星期六跟老婆孩子吃顿饭，
然后当天晚上再杀回杭州吗，
那也太折腾了，
对不对，
就待一天，
甚至待个半天，
当大家都在那边开会，
几个创始人，
带着员工一起开会的时候，
就你这个创始人不在，
你能接受吗，
带员工去团建，
你不在能接受吗，
对吧,
投资人啊，
或者说是合伙人啊，
或者其他一些同行，
约一起去开个会吃个饭，
所以这个事情，
往往你在这个齿轮里面，
你是不可控的，
但是你无根的话，
去哪都一样，
放手一搏，
老婆也支持你，
那你就是完完全全，
就是另外一种创业的状态了，
当然了，
人生是自己选的，
我觉得我现在状态也挺好，
那张雪觉得说，
他那个状态也挺好，
那是OK的，
就每个人找好自己的节奏，
所以你看啊，
张雪这个人，
小时候没有资源，
他去修车，
修车又绝对不够，
他去追这个，
湖南的这个采访电视台记者，
说你能不能采访我，
我要当车手，
那么真的进到车队里面，
又发现，
车手这条路则不通，
他就想说，
哎,
我想学造车，
他自己也是，
通过啊，
各种各样肯定也是，
托朋友啊，
面试啊，
讲自己的经历啊，
也不知道怎么样，
反正这段经历没查到，
他去到浙江，
进工厂打螺丝了，
他要自己去，
手搓摩托车，
不能叫造车，
就手搓摩托车，
搞这个改装，
搞拼装，
拼装没有壁垒，
门槛比较低嘛，
但是他至少也是个手艺活，
他懂摩托车，
然后别人去山寨他，
抄起他，
那不行我做设计，
设计在抄，
那不行我就做发动机，
我就做品牌，
对吧,
那慢慢一步一步，
最后,
终于有一些合伙的人，
看到他了，
觉得这个人是有水平，
有技术的，
那么一起合伙去做一个品牌，
凯乐,
那么凯乐坐着坐着发现，
有一些经营上的分歧，
他就出来，
以自己的名字，
2024年,
就打造了，
章雪机车，
就没想到这么快，
也可能是他这个方向走的是对的，
三缸机，
轻量化，
那个车子也不是一般人能，
一般人能能，
能 hold 住的，
我那天看到那个，
急速拍档的柏林，
柏林,
柏林他去试这个车，
他就讲了这么一句话，
我觉得很有道理，
因为我看到网上，
很多人评价这个820RR，
说他的这个转速特别的灵敏，
就像个野狗一样，
他就像游车跟电车的区别，
就是你那个油门轻轻一点，
油门稍微这么一开，
那个转速直接就伸上去了，
他说哪怕你就是开过那种公升级的，
他当时讲过一句话叫什么，
叫做,
公升以下我无敌，
公升以上一对一，
一换一，
还不叫一对一啊，
公升以上一换一，
这句话当时是怎么解释的，
这个王伯托车的人都知道，
就我也不懂伯托车，
我也不用展开，
因为我相信90%的人都不懂，
懂的人自然就懂了，
就是说他对于这个伯托车的理解，
他要他自己的一套逻辑，
那么有些人上手这个车的时候，
会觉得他是个疯子，
怎么会把这个车调得这么的疯狂，
但是他可能这个规矩或者说这个逻辑，
他就特别适合塞到，
而且正好也遇到了那个很牛逼的车手，
让他也特别能够掌握这个车的一些性能，
那么在弯道里面就游人有余，
直线他的极速干不过别人，
但是他弯道上面，
就是我们讲跑得快不是直线跑得快，
是比谁的弯道能够硬吃对方，
深吃对方能跑得快，
所以说这个可能是有他的决策性上面的一些讨巧，
也有他的一种指念在这里面，
那么最终打造出了这么一个。
类似于性能怪兽的这么一个机器，
正好又切中了这个游戏规则，
卡了一个bug，
或者说他确实这个产品也很好，
他也有这道推特理解，
或者他已经这么多年，
几十年，二十多年，
就一直在研究怎么在赛道里面，
能够夺得冠军，
他对于规则的理解，
对于产品的理解，
就形成了一套完整的体系，
结果一战成名，
这个东西我觉得这个名誉是该他得的，
但是呢，
我个人觉得就是他现在目前，
语意还没有完全分满的情况下，
有这么大的一个光环照在他的身上，
那么到底是，
今后的路会更加的充满经济，
还是说充满着惊喜，
这个不得而知，
因为张雪本人，
87年我觉得还算年轻一点，
他比我小三岁，
就40岁真是闯荡的年纪嘛，
对不对，
而且你看叫张雪，
前段时间张雪峰老师，
就不幸离世了，
就张雪，张雪峰就差一个字，
就有些时候明明之中，
同一年就是前后一两个月，
就两件这种出圈的事件，
是不是叫这个名字的人都很牛啊，
也要注意身体，
对吧，还是要注意身体，
哎,
就现在中国的这种摩托士的大环境啊，
能出现这么一个企业真的不容易啊，
你想想看，
摩托车应该是13年报废吧，
还是十几年，
然后呢，
在地球上应该说是。
现磨城市最多的，
咱们中国是吧，
我们南京是全国数一数二的，
叫北京，上海，
南京这车牌照，
摩托车的车牌照，
那归得要命啊，
然后呢摩托车还有各种限制，
然后前段时间我跟我舅舅聊天，
我舅舅跟我讲说，
现在他的摩托车已经不能起了，
我说为什么，
他说70岁以上的老人，
不允许骑摩托车，
因为他的驾照呢，
是被强行降级啊，
已经降到了F照，
F照就是只能骑轻磨，
大家都知道轻磨，
除非你手上有一块，
像我们南京是现牌的嘛，
你除非有一块轻磨的牌照，
就是那个蓝牌，
你还能骑一起，
你要是没有这个牌照，
不可能有人为了，
骑轻磨去买轻磨，
基本上不会有，
你轻磨，
你不如骑一个电动自行车了，
是不是，
这个说的有点迂远了，
反正总而言之，
就是现在国内的这种大环境对摩托车，
我觉得不是特别的友好，
在这种情况下能出现，
像张雪这样的一个，
把摩托车当成梦想，
而且以此真的去付出实践，
而且做出成绩的人，
我们应该去给他一些称赞，
我们应该去给他鼓掌，
喝彩,
那如果作为自媒体同行，
或者是媒体同行，
不要去打扰他，
让他安安稳稳的，
但他需要我们的时候，
我们去出现，
而不是给他去加那么多的一些，
这个行而上的，
或者说是上价值的东西，
我觉得没有任何的意义，
对吧,
所以也是希望张雪能够经营后，
这条路是越走越好，
越走越好，
那目前来看的话，
很多的资源已经开始往他这边去倾斜了，
但是一定要小心，
就是资本的入场，
其实这背后啊，
它是资本失血的，
它是要快速的，
去把这一笔资金争到手，
快速的离场，
所以这个对于一种实体产业，
它不一定是好事，
不一定是好事，
哎，可能是我想多了，
最后啰嗦了两句，
可能我作为一个创业者，
设身处地的，
我是把它当成一个，
可能是小老弟，
因为他比我小三岁嘛，
小老弟，
对吧,
当成是个同行，
我就是在节目当中收个两三句，
也许我的节目里面也有人认识他，
对吧,
说哎,
三刀有些节目聊了你啊，
就发给他，
他要是无聊的时候开着车子，
他不会开车，
这个骑着摩托车，
塞着蓝牙耳机，
这样也不安全，
他不忙的时候，
可能听听咱们的节目，
对吧,
哎,
觉得根本说得挺有道理，
反正热爱可抵岁月漫长，
也能冲破所有的壁垒，
反正张雪的故事呢，
我觉得真的，
很燃,
非常的燃，
那么现在他一夜成名，
那无论是从资本市场，
还是政府的层面，
甚至包括网红圈子，
都开始有人关注他，
想蹭流量，
所以我希望，
这个张雪小老弟啊，
能够保持出行，
就是不要受外界的干扰，
认认真真的，
把中国的摩托车造好，
好吧,
行啊,
以上就是关于张雪的，
所有的这个故事的内容，
希望大家喜欢，
如果觉得节目不错呢，
可以点赞评论跟转发，
那么每期节目，
我们在留言区，
会抽取三位，
赠送由认言记，
提供的这个，
预录相离，
试试装，
每一盒里面有五颗，
那么同时呢，
在小宇宙跟喜马拉雅，
如果没有点关注的，
听到这了嘛，
大家都是缘分，
能不能动动发起来的小手指，
点一波关注，
关注一波不迷路啊，
每周三，
每周六更新会有提醒，
那么同时呢，
如果喜马拉雅的听有，
有免费的月票，
听三十分钟以上，
会送一张，
平台会免费给到你，
能不能投给我，
如果投给我的话，
我的节目的曝光啊，
排名啊，
会更高，
那么以上呢，
就是节目的主要内容，
那么接下来呢，
还有留言互动，
这也是我们听有给我的建议，
说不要总是说，
到了这个位置讲，
节目就以上内容啊，
你要说，
以上是主要内容，
下面是留言互动，
那么上期节目呢，
我们是，
聊了这个，
关于这个质价，
就是小鹏的VLA的二代，
那么其中有位听友叫，
LouisKVGG,。
他说,
刀哥,
我之前是在喜马拉雅，
我现在在小宇宙听你节目，
第一次留言，
他说我提个醒啊，
这个SoRU啊，
它其实不是，
仓价一体的这个芯片，
只是算力跟它的存储的贷宽，
比之前提高了，
它其实还算是质价的芯片，
高通的8775，
8797,
它是属于叫，
仓价一体的这个芯片，
所以他说，
想提醒一下，
非常感谢，
因为在评论区我看到，
还有一些朋友也提到这一点，
说这个稍微的修正一下，
不是仓价一体的，
好，那么下面一位听友叫做，
听友541036884,。
他说,
刀哥你好，
我听了刀哥一年多的节目，
我本身是个挨人，
我的语言组织能力不是很强，
那么加上呢，
又是在车上听节目，
所以也是第一次留言，
节目当中，
刀哥你说，
这个L3来临的时候啊，
大家会不会感发自己的生命，
交给这一辆，
这个自动驾驶的车辆，
我想说的是，
目前L2加的智能驾驶辅助，
就已经有很多人赶在车上睡觉了，
那么到L3的时候，
肯定会有更多的人敢这么去用的，
他说,
我呢是一个刚走上社会的这个应届毕业生，
我最后提个问题，
就刀哥你对于这几年的毕业的，
这种本科生大专生的出路在哪，
哪个行业是星星相容，
能不能给一点建议，
说句实在话，
现在这种大环境下，
你让我给建议，
我也给不了，
我不能让你去做自媒体当网红啊，
我只想说一句话，
就是你仔细想一想，
或者是盘算盘算，
手上的资源，
以及你愿意这一辈子未知付出的这个梦想是什么，
这可能说的后半段有点需要，
我们先说前半段啊，
你手上的资源，
你作为一个应届毕业生，
你肯定是没有资源的嘛，
那么这里面你就要看到第一个，
你的亲戚啊，
直系的亲属，
父母,
甚至于包括你父母身边的周围的朋友，
中国是人情社会，
你刚开始在社会上的第一步，
你不要装清高，
说哎呀，
我不要动用你们的关系，
我自己着工作，
我有这个实力，
你就是一个应届毕业生，
你有什么实力啊，
你有什么在大学期间，
拿到什么国家级奖项啊，
什么科研成果啊，
或者说你有什么独门手艺啊，
你真的有，
你也不会这么这么去问了，
你就是一个每一年千万级的这个毕业生当中的，
其中一个微不足道的小城安，
一个小牛马，
那这个话说的可能有点难听啊，
我想讲的是，
你既然已经走上社会了，
你也不甘愿去当一个普通的牛马，
你也是希望自己的这个职业生涯能够走得更顺，
那么起步阶段，
有你的父母，
亲戚朋友去托举一下，
有什么不好的呢，
其实你走上社会无非就是第一个掌握自己的技能，
第二个，
你要去有一定的社会的人脉资源，
这两件事情是缺一不可的，
那么最终接得下来的时候，
你就是换取一定的财富嘛，
对不对，
你现在评价这个人混得好不好，
那无非就是看他挣得多不多嘛，
那挣得多不多，
你说怎么叫做挣得多呢，
你除非是有一个独门技术，
这个企业少了你不行，
少了你明天就垮掉，
科研院所，
没有你这个专家，
这个院所这个名气不够，
或者说是也出不了成果，
那你是牛班，
那你可以就是，
肆意妄为对吧，
你可以发脾气什么都可以，
但是你没这个能力，
你是一个随时随地能被人替换掉的，
这个牛马，
那你又是个毕业生，
刚开始走入社会，
你有什么资格去选择呢，
所以,
我们讲第一个就是资源，
算一下家里的资源，
能动用的资源到底有哪些，
先往这个行业里面，
起步稍微往上抬一抬，
然后呢，
稍微起步的时候轻松一点，
有一些正反馈，
工资收入也好，
人脉资源也好，
岗位的这个，
我们讲就是它的能接触到核心圈，
核心的这个资源圈，
先放到这个位置上，
慢慢的混，
不要着急，
那么第二个我们讲到就是，
这个个人的能力了，
对吧,
就是说，
你作为什么梦想啊，
这些东西去追逐，
你有没有自己的爱好，
有没有在大学期间既止不挣钱，
你也愿意坚持的爱好啊，
那如果有的话，
这个能不能往他那个方向走呢，
那今天张雪的这个故事，
其实你应该能听得出来，
他本身对于摩托车就这个爱好，
其实,
我是不主张禁摩他，
因为我一直认为，
对于那些买不起汽车的人来讲，
摩托车是提升他出行效率，
最高的一个交通工具，
没有之一，
那么为什么要剥夺这些人，
高效的一个出行的效率的交通工具呢，
为什么要剥夺他，
凭什么，
是不是，
就像你现在把电动自行车都要一刀切，
还要做成这种，
什么国标型的，
要满吞吞的，
有的时候建议是后座不带人，
后座不带人，
你觉得可能吗，
每天上午你看看，
早上学校门口接送孩子的那些家长，
那只能说是，
政策归政策，
执行归执行吗，
对不对，
那摩托车现在各个城市，
你说禁摩不禁摩，
那你说南京那边市区牌照，
还是郊区牌照，
我看现在郊区禁市区，
也没啥，
但是这个可能是，
音频播客电台讲讲没关系啊，
这个我在微博上当时，
怎么讲呢，
就是发了一条，
也不能叫吐槽吧，
就有点调侃这个，
新国标电动自行车的，
当天那个帖子就被删掉了嘛，
是不是，
那作为没有钱买得起，
汽车的这一部分人，
那摩托车是不是他的一个，
能够大大提升效率的，
一个交通工具呢，
那为什么不让他起，
为什么全程都禁，
为什么要一刀切，
那当然讲的有点跑偏了，
其实我觉得就是在整个的这个，
你定义未来自己的，
发展方向的时候，
想一想哪个是你热爱的，
你真的愿意为之付出，
后面十年二十年都不变，
你就扎根这个行业，
或者就是你起步的时候啊，
父母亲戚朋友周围的一些，
这个人脉关系，
能够把你往一个核心的岗位上去掉一掉，
人脉资源好一点，
收入高一点，
让你起步有个真反馈，
这也是OK的，
好吧,
当然我的建议不一定都完全对啊，
我们评论区也可以探讨，
下面一位听友呢，
他的名字叫做图图想静静，
他说他的老弟呢，
想买一辆小冯机器，
三图灵的版本，
但是呢他的车计呢，
又比较差，
而且一年呢，
也开不到五千公里，
他跟他的爱人呢，
是在两个城市工作，
相隔大概120公里，
平时一周见一次面，
主要是他老婆开车来找他，
因为他呢，
一开车就觉得累，
他也不想开车，
所以他现在考虑把手上的这个车换掉，
想买一个带制驾的，
他也是考虑到小冯制驾比较好嘛，
所以说，
他就特别希望，
就用这个智能驾驶辅助，
去跑长途，
但是他的建议就是说，
你还是要去练自己的车计，
你的车计，
才是,
保证你驾驶安全的最核心的要素，
你将来遇到什么问题，
你知道你人知道该怎么去处理，
你不能完全依赖制驾，
所以说，
他现在这个选车的方式啊，
他就很担心，
你要是担心他的出行安全，
这个呢，
说句实在话，
很简单，
你就收集一些这个智能驾驶的事故的案例，
越惨越好，
你让他看，
让他反复地看，
你强制他看，
把他的眼皮子给撑着，
你让他看了那些惨恋的画面之后啊，
让他形成PTSD，
肌肉肌液，
他以后就知道了，
就智能驾驶，
智能是辅助，
他甚至于可能这个买车的方式都变了，
我不要支架了，
我就老老实实开了，
我就油门踩在自己的脚底下，
刹车踩到自己脚底下，
扶着方向盘就更安全，
那只能这样吗，
那还得怎么办呢，
你尊重他人命运，
你如果就这样子让他看视频，
他都接受不了，
你让他支架去开呗，
对吧,
你让他支架开，
你就跟他说速度放慢一点嘛，
支架本身也会有一定的限速嘛，
支架开，
就算出了一些问题，
我说句实在话，
小缝小擦，
运气比较好，
在市区，
装个车，
蹭个树，
装个什么，
当然千万别撞人啊，
就装个什么这个忽兰之类的，
一次两次他其实就清楚了，
就这个东西啊，
他没有那么好用，
不是那么智能，
就有些事情就是人交人交不会嘛，
就事交人一次就会嘛，
对不对，
你苦口薄心的跟他讲这个讲那个，
我相信你讲的已经很多了，
他不听就是不听，
那怎么办呢，
对不对，
我们作为媒体来讲，
也只能是告诉大家，
他就是个辅助，
他也会出现，
可能千分之一万分之一的这种，
系统的一些失误，
那你不能完全去相信他，
那有的人就是闭着眼睛看他怎么办的，
好吧,
那么以上就本期节目所有的内容给大家收听啊，
如果大家呢，
想要关注主播的更多内容，
可以在bilibili搜索，
我们专辑的同名叫摆车全说，
那么是长视频的平台，
还有就是短视频，
像这个抖音啊，
视频号啊，
小红书快手啊，
搜索三刀砍车，
砍就是单人旁砍大厂的砍，
还有个人的微博叫摆车全说三刀，
想要进我们的社群的话，
也可以关注一下我们公众号，
叫摆车全说，
也可以添加微信，
想跟我一对一的交流加这个微信，
46415254,。
今天这一期到这里，
我们下期接着聊，
拜拜!